thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez a silver
alert has been issued in nevada tonight
after a couple from indianapolis went
missing while they were driving through
our state last week ron and beverly
barker left their home near oregon in
the area of eugene less than a week ago
with plans to make it to the state of
arizona so what we know is they were
actually last seen not too far from reno
here in stagecoach and then their cell
phones last pinged to tower just a
little further south here actually in
coal dale madison kimbrough speaking to
the couple's nephew who is holding out
hope that they will return home safely
after speaking to ron and beverly's
nephew travis it's clear that the
couple's disappearance is out of the
ordinary as he's described both of them
as being technologically savvy and aware
of their surroundings
they've been missing out for eight days
where are ronnie and beverly travis
peters wanting answers as to where his
aunt and uncle are the indiana couple
was last seen traveling through nevada
in their rv authorities from both
esmeralda and nye counties assisting in
the search they were taking a trip out
west with two of their best friends from
indianapolis at some point in the last
few weeks they separated with their
friends ronnie and beverly
continued up to oregon
to visit relatives in oregon and then
they were going to meet back together
in tucson arizona and then they were
going to work their way back to
indianapolis everything was fine they
left
albany oregon last saturday morning the
26th they left oregon they traveled to
mammoth lake california where they spent
the night in their rv their next stop
would have been fallon nevada but peters
believes instead of stopping there they
continued on heading south towards coal
dale and that's when things went dark
the barkers were driving a 2015 forest
river sun seeker class c rv with indiana
plates along with towing a white 2020
kia soul lx also with indiana plates we
know that they stopped for fuel in
stagecoach nevada we have video of them
pumping gas you can see my aunt get out
and go to the back of the rv that video
was taken on sunday march 27th and that
was the last time they were seen in
person
as of now nevada state police has issued
a silver alert that of which isn't
normally done for out of state residents
but after reaching out to northern
command we were told the chief made an
exception live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now
madison thank you and